watering her crops hilary pavatt has
repurposed her garden to grow vegetables
to help eventually feed herself and her
family during the coronavirus crisis
she's one of millions of Britons now
sowing seeds to try and become more
self-sufficient after realizing that
food supply chains are fragile
we've started planting potatoes we've
got vegetables in cut again in salads
stuff for the winter so hopefully in
about I'd say six weeks we'll start to
be self self-sufficient so I think and
obviously there's going to be the
problem with how produce is going to end
up in the supermarket's because you know
they can't get the migrant workers to
come in
there's lockdown so you know in the end
there's going to end up being shortages
I think you know in weeks to come so
hopefully I hope I'll be all right
others without gardens are using what
space they have to germinate tomatoes
cucumbers and herbs Britain's wartime
generation were told to dig for victory
and responded with enthusiasm
having Britain's reliance on food
imports by the early 1940s
now households with time on their hands
are returning to the garden the Royal
Horticultural Society has seen a surge
in visits to its website seeking advice
on how to grow your own vegetables fruit
and edible plants while seed
manufacturers are reporting a massive
rise in sales in recent weeks in
supermarkets most panic buying has eased
but egg shelves are often still bare
considered a staple of the pandemic
country live poultry breeders across the
UK have seen their farms stripped of
birds as families unable to find eggs in
the shops turned to chicken keeping
Sussex poultry farmer Liz and Roxie has
now decided to stop selling chickens
anxious that some might regret their
impulse buys when the lockdown is lifted
and I've never had so many people call
text Nemo like I said it takes me a good
month to sell the stock that I get in
and within a week I had sold all my some
of my leftover February birds and my mom
watch Birds so it was that huge panic I
think for people to suddenly go oh my
god I can't get my eggs the UK currently
imports 85% of its vegetables from the
European Union but there are concerns
lengthy quarantines could disrupt food
supply chains turning to the soil rather
than the supermarket for fresh produce
could ease that burden charlie Angela al
Jazeera Hampshire